كل عام وانتم وكل يعني للعاملين بالعربيه
بالف خير بطبع متابعه سوق الاسهم السعوديه
تمثل المحتوى الاكبر لنا ضمن نشرات
الاقتصاد بدايه بفقرات تحديث الاسواق على
قناه العربيه منذ الصباح التي تعطي
المستثمر معلومات موجزه حول ابرز ما يحرك
الاسواق خلال اليوم سواء عالميا او محليا
وايضا اهم ما تتراقبه الاسواق من بيانات
واجتماعات مهمه وهو ما حارسنا عليهم منذ
انطلاق الاسواق العربيه تقديم كل ما يهم
المستثمر بشكل خاص نبض السوق الاسواق
العربيه غداء عمل وجرس الاغلاق برامج
اصبحت مرجعا للاعلام الاقتصادي منذ ان
انطلقت عام 2005 بفريقها المتخصص بخبره
صحفيه واعلاميه واقتصاديه وماليه فريق
واكبا دون ملل اهم وابرز الاخبار والاحداث
والمتغيرات التي حركت جوانب الاقتصاد
وقادت مختلف قطاعات المال والاع محليا في
منطقه الخليج وفي مقدمتها السوق السعوديه
وعربيا وعالميا على مدار السنوات الماضيه
وحتى الان وهو ما سنواصل الالتزام به
اليوم وغدا سوق الاسهم السعوديه كان لها
نصيب الاسد من تغطيتنا منذ البدايه
2006 عام القمه والقاع العام الذي تغيرت
بعده اليه عمل سوق الاسهم والسوق الماليه
السعوديه ليفتح المجال امام تطوير
التشريعات والقوانين واللوائح المنظمه
للسوق من حيث التداول وتشديد المراقبه
وفرض الغرامات على المخالفين 2006 لا ينسى
ما حدا لتغيير منظومه العمل في السوق
لتعزز مكانه تداول كاهم واكبر سوق عربي
بقيمه سوقيه تتجاوز التريليون و700 مليار
دولار حاليا فما الذي حدث في 2006 هو عام
لن ننساه كان العامل اكثر تقلبا وتاثيرا
بدءا من القمه التي بلغها تاسي في 25
[تصفيق]
هذه مستويات قياسيه جديده نراها على سوق
الاسهم السعوديه ويبدو اننا نقترب جدا من
حاجز 21 الف نقطه اليوم ارتفاع ب 340 نقاط
او ما يعادل واحد ونصف في المئه على مؤشر
سوق الاسهم السعوديه الذي يقف الان عند
20,000
نقطه اليوم سوق الاسهم السعوديه تسجل
تراجعات حاده الي يبدو انه عند الاغلاق
مؤشر السوق يخسر اكثر من ثلاثه في المئه
عدد كبير من الشركات تغلق على انخفاض
بالحد الاقصى المسموح به قيمه للتداول لم
تتجاوز 7 مليار بينما تعودنا انها تتجاوز
45 مليار او تقريبا مليار اربعين مليار
خلال الفتره الماضيه هل يدلك على ان هناك
عدم قناعه كثيره في قضيه المضاربه
وبالتالي اتضحت المساله انه من الغير
المنطقي هذه الاسعار الكثير من الشركات
وبالتالي الى الجميع رغب بالتخلص من هذه
الشركات
[موسيقى]
غير انه شكلي كان مختلف تماما عم نحكي عن
17 سنه لورا ولكن كانت اياما صعبه بالفعل
خاصه لانه بحينها كان جميع السعوديين
لديهم اسهم وبالتالي كانت ظاهره شراء
افراد وبالتالي عند الوصول الى القمه ومن
ثم النزول الصعب الذي حدث بالسوق فقد
الكثير جنى عمرهم وبالتالي كانت ايام صعبه
ومليئه بالالم لانه عم نتحدث عن خساره عدد
كبير من الناس لجنى العمر بالتالي من هنا
بدات الحاجه
للتشريعات التي لحقت بعد ذلك بالطبع كان
لنشرات قسم الاقتصاد في العربيه الحضور
والتواجد الاكثر بين اوساط المستثمرين
والمهتمين باسواق المال من السعوديين
لمتابعه حزم التغييرات التي اعاقبت هبوط
سوق الاسهم والتي كانت بوتيره شبه يوميه
كان لنا لقاءات حصريه مع المسؤولين
السعوديين في تصريحات كان يترقبها
الكثيرون لحظه بلحظه
[موسيقى]
ومنذ تاسيس الهيئه عمل جماس سحيمي الرئيس
السابق لهيئه السوق الماليه على الارتقاء
بنوعيه التداولات في السوق السعوديه وهو
الدور الذي تعاهد الرئيس الجديد الدكتور
عبد الرحمن التويجري بالعمل على تطويره في
المرحله المقبله نتراجع الكبير في اسعار
الاسهم
لكن
للقلق لتاثيره المباشر على ملايين
المواطنين ولا يتلائم مع الوضع الاقتصادي
العامه الذي تعيشه بلادنا من ازدهارنا
الاقتصادي والتي تتمتع فيه بمعدلاته نمو
عاليه
في ميزانيه الحكومه وميزان المدفوعات ولا
يوجد تضخم
[موسيقى]
على كلن يعني هذا التغيير اللي حدث بحينها
كان الناس يحتاجون الى رؤيه تغيير يحتاجون
الى رؤيه اخذ المسؤولين بجديه الخساره
الضخمه التي حصلت في السوق السعوديه منذ
ذلك الحين بظن تاخذ القرار انه يتحول
السوق الى مؤسساتي ادخال المؤسسات المحليه
والعالميه لحتى يصير استثمار الافراد يشكل
نسبه اقل من السوق ولا يعود سوق متقلب على
هوى استثمارات الافراد وليس المؤسسات فاذا
التحول الاكبر نحو العالميه بدا فعليا من
بعد سلسله خطوات ولكن بيونيو 2015 مع
السماح للمستثمرين الاجانب المؤهلين
بالدخول في السوق الماليه السعوديه بعد ان
تم تحديث قواعد وشروط استثمار الاجانب
مرتين خلال عامي 2016 و2018 كما كانت ابرز
ثمار منظومه حزم الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
والماليه بعد اعوام قليله من اطلاق رؤيه
المملكه 2030 هي ترقيه سوق الاسهم
السعوديه الى مصاف الاسواق الناشئه في عام
2019 من قبل اكبر ثلاث شركات عالميه
للمؤشرات ام السي اي فوت راسل واسم بيدا
جونز
[موسيقى]
سوق الاسهم السعوديه عن كثب وذلك لانه بدا
منها اليوم يستطيع المستثمر الاجنبي شراء
المباشر في سوق عبر
ترخيص يحصل عليه كاكيو اف اي فايف
[موسيقى]
نادين بالفعل يعني التقارير ايجابيه جدا
حول انعكاس فتحه السوق السعوديه على اسواق
المنطقه بشكل عام وتحديدا اسواق الامارات
[موسيقى]
صعب واحد يشوف حاله من سنوات فريق الاسواق
العربيه تواجد بشكل بارز اثناء التحضيرات
الاوليه وحتى الادراج الاكبر في السوق
السعوديه حيث شهد ديسمبر من عام 2019
المحطه الاهم الاكبر ظهورا في عناوين
الاخبار الاقتصاديه محليا وعالميا هي طرح
ارامكو الذي جمع سته وتسعين مليار ريال او
25 مليار و600 مليون دولار ليكون في حينها
اكبر اكتتاب عام في تاريخ اسواق الاسهم
العالميه ومع اكتتاب ارامكو اصبحت سوق
الاسهم السعوديه في ذلك الحين تاسع اكبر
بورصه في العالم بقيمه سوقيه لشركات
المدرجه تصل الى تريليونين و300 مليار
دولار بعد طول انتظار تستقبل سوق الاسهم
السعوديه اليوم سهم ارامكو بعد انتهاء
الاكتتاب العام الاولي الاكبر في العالم
بقيمه 25 مليارا 600 مليون دولار بطلبات
شراء فاقد الاسهم المعروضه
بما يقارب خمسه اضعاف
ادراج اسهم ارامكو تحت مظله
[موسيقى]
المؤشر
وعلى الرغم من الظروف المفاجئه والصعبه
التي فرضتها ازمه تفشي كورونا بالاعوام
الثلاثه الماضيه الا ان سوق السعوديه وصلت
التطوير والتحديات ليتم الاعلان عن ادراج
وتداول اسهم شركه مجموعه تداول السعوديه
القابضه تم ادراجها بالسوق الرئيسيه
اعتبارا من الثامن من ديسمبر 2021 وذلك
بعد تحولها الى شركه قابضه باسم مجموعه
تداول السعوديه قباله طرح العام الاولي
ياتي الطرح كتويج لنشاط الطروحات العامه
الاوليه ليزداد عمق السوق مع تنوع
المنتجات والادوات الاستثماريه المدرجه
فيها بعدد يتجاوز 220 شركه حاليا ماذا
تغير في الهيكل الجديد شركه السوق الماليه
تداول تحولت الى شركه قابضه باسم مجموعه
تداول السعوديه وتحت مظلتها اربع شركات هي
تداول كسوق للاوراق الماليه وشركه مركز
مقاصه الاوراق الماليه مقاصه وشركه مركز
ايد اوراق الماليه ايداع وشركه مومنت
الجديده والمتخصصه في الخدمات والحلول
التقنيه القائمه على الابتكار وبدا اليوم
ادراج وتداول سهم شركه مجموعه تداول
السعوديه القابضه في السوق الرئيسيه بعد
ان تم الاكتتاب بالاسهم بسعر 105
قد طرحت 36 مليون سهم تمثل 30% من
راسمالها للاكتتاب العام تم تخصيص 70%
منها للشركات و30% للافراد
التغطيه او الاسواق العربيه بشكل لتعرفونه
الان لم يبدا مع انطلاقه العربيه
بالتالي لا نستطيع اختصار مسيره 18 عاما
من التغطيه لاسواق المنطقه وخاصه سوق
الاسهم السعوديه واخبار المنطقه ببضع
الدقائق هذه كانت بعض المحطات لكن ربما
الانجاز الاكبر هو انه اعتاد الناس على
متابعه الاخبار الاقتصاديه معنا اصبحت
ضروره ان يتابعوننا ويعلمون بكل ما يدور
من اخبار اقتصاديه في المنطقه لانها
بالفعل تمس بحياتهم اليوميه كون ايضا دول
الخليج هي مقر الاستثمارات ضخمه فاذا
العبره لا نستطيع ان نختصرها بالماضي
وبهذه الفقره بل بالحاضر والمستقبل نعطكم
بان نبقى السباقين فيه بتغطيه سوق الاسهم
السعوديه وغيرها من الاسواق والاخبار
الاقتصاديه